[Music]
in this morning's eye on money how the
coronavirus is affecting the red hot
housing market august sales of existing
homes hit the highest level
in nearly 14 years soaring more than
10 percent from a year ago but inventory
is low
there were nearly 2 million fewer homes
available and then at the same time last
year
cbs news business analyst jill
schlesinger joins us to help make sense
of these changes jill good morning
first of all why is the housing market
booming
well i think that there are a lot of
factors that are combining it is
really clear that our nature of where we
live and how we work
has shifted with the pandemic so we
already had a very buoyant market before
the pandemic
a lot of people all of a sudden they're
home they realize uh oh i don't really
like my house or i don't like renting
or gosh my kids are with me all those
factors really encouraging people to
leave cities leave their old homes look
for new homes and of course mortgage
rates are
very very low and this is encouraging a
hot housing market but as you noted
the inventory the number of homes for
sale has dropped dramatically
and the number of homes for sale really
is
the determining factor of supply and
demand so we have just seen an
almost frenzy to get going here i want
to remind you though of course if you're
looking for a house you shouldn't be
deterred by this hot housing market
but you've got to run your numbers
you've got to budget and have that
home down payment in a safe place not at
risk in the market
and you know get that pre-approval try
to look beyond the pandemic because
i know we're in the middle of this right
now but things could
shift in the next couple of years you're
probably buying a house for the next 20
or 30 years
well you talk about the low inventory
which leads to bidding wars
and so when is it when do you decide
about whether you should get into a
bidding war
i feel like this is a little bit of a
deja vu
in a lot of markets it almost feels like
2004-2005 again
real estate firm redfin says that over
the last four months
over 54 percent of the bids that they've
submitted have been part
of bidding wars oh it's hard to imagine
now the really important fact here is
it's okay to be in a bidding war as long
as you have run the numbers
and calculated the top end where you can
go
my worry is as a former financial
planner
is that people blow through what they've
budgeted for their house
and they ask for problems down the line
so stick to your numbers
and don't get emotional really try to
walk away
you know anthony i've always told you
this my mother used to be a realtor and
she used to say
a house is like a man there's more than
one for you in the world
go mom go mom thank you mom
[Laughter]
so you make you mention the cities a lot
of people are leaving
the cities because of the pandemic
what's that doing to the housing market
i mean
it's it's a seller's market probably
except in the cities right now right
that's absolutely true and you can look
at areas like new york or
in the bay area where we're seeing
people flee the city
and really look for more room i think
that there's a really
interesting aspect to this which is
people leaving the cities we
had a whole trend towards urbanization
now i don't know if that's really going
to be a permanent trend it's one we
should look at
i should also really be clear that a lot
of the move away from the cities
has been young people who have left
their rental apartments
and moved back home we got a stunning
figure from pew research it just blew my
mind
right now 18 to 29 year olds 52 percent
have gone back to their homes i know
you're
feeling this anthony because you might
feel you're in your own home
52 percent are living home do you know
that is the highest
number of young adults living home since
the great depression i don't know
whether or not that's going to persist
but what we do know is those gen z folks
boy they love paying down their
student loan debt and they like saving
money so anthony you might have company
for a while yeah well i had a daughter
who moved
out and about a month later she moved
back in jill i know how it feels
thank you very much jill schlesinger